هالك تصريحات لوزير الدفاع
البريطاني عن هذه الغارات مجمل ما جاء في
هذه التصريحات اساد
الله نعم زين البيان المشترك الامريكي
البريطاني
لخص يعني النقاط الرئيسيه في الموقف
المشترك سواء البريطاني او الامريكي منان
هذه الغارات يعني هي جوله جديده ضد اتاف
للحوثيين وانها ركزت على المخزونات
الاسلحه والصواريخ المخباه على اعماق بحسب
وسائل الاعلام البريطانيه تم استخدام 24
طائره تحمل قنابل من نوع البنكر
باستر المدمره للتحصينات او التي تستهدف
التحصينات على اعماق كبيره تزل تصل زنه
بعض هذه القنابل الى 2000 رطل بالنسبه
لوزير الدفاع البريطاني من ضمن ما قاله
زين ان هذه ال هجمات لا تعتبر تصعيدا وان
الموقف البريطاني يفهم منه هذا ان الموقف
البريطاني ما زال يدعو الحوثيين للتراجع
عن شن هجمات على السخن في البحر الاحمر
بالطبع زين ليست هذه الموجه الاولى من
الهجمات البريطانيه الامريكيه على اهداف
تابعه لجماعه انصار الله الحوثيين في بري
عفوا في اليمن ولكن يبدو منها ان الرساله
ان الهجمات
ستستمر اذا استمرت هجمات جماعه انصار
الحوثيين
على السفن العابره سواء في البحر الاحمر
او في خليج عدن بالنسبه لوزير الدفاع
البريطاني جران شابس وحسب عده وسائل اعلام
هنا في
بريطانيا هو شدد كما قلنا على انها ليست
تصعيدا وبالتالي الموقف البريطاني مازال
متحفظا هو قال ايضا ان الهجمات تمت ب نجاح
على مواقع اطلاق الصواريخ وايضا على مواقع
تخزين
هذه الصواريخ التي تستخدم في الهجمات
الصادره من اليمن ضد السفن وزير الدفاع
جراند شاتس قال ايضا انه على ثقه من ان
هذه الموجه من الهجمات يعني قد حققت نتائج
اكبر من الهجمات الساب السابقه من حيث
تقويه قدرات جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
الصاروخيه وق راتهم على شن هجمات كالتي
شنوها في الاشهر الماضيه على حركه الملاحه
في هذه المنطقه الحيويه من العالم كرر
ايضا وزير الدفاع
البريطاني عفوا بان يعني م قاله في السابق
من ان الهجمات التي تصدر من جماعه انصار
الله
الحوثيين هي هجمات كما يقول غير قانونيه
وغير مقبوله وكرر ايضا ما قاله في بيانات
سابقه من ان هذه الهجمات البريطانيه
الامريكيه كانت متناسبه و تارجت بمعنى
انها لها اهداف محدده يفهم من هذا في
مواقف سابقه مثلا زين انه
تم يعني المحاوله بقدر الامكان للابتعاد
عن اصابه اي اهداف مدنيه وانه كما قالت
الحكومه البريطانيه في
السابق يتم اختيار التوقيت الليلي لشن هذه
الهجمات من اجل تقليل عدد الخسا اسد الله
وانت تحدثنا الان نتابع هذه الصور هذه
الصور للمقاتلات
البريطانيه وهي تنطلق لتنفيذ هذه الهجمات
على
اليمن صحيح هذه الصور اذاعتها وسائل اعلام
بريطانيه زين وهذه الصور عاده يعني تظهر
المقاتلات البريطانيه من نوع تايفون وهي
تلط تنطلق من القواعد البريطانيه سيما في
قاعده اكروتيري في قبرص هذه المره لم يحدد
بعد من قبل الحكومه البريطانيه من اين
انطلقت الطائرات ولكن بحسب البيان
الطائرات الامريكيه والبريطانيه انطلقت من
يعني حاملات طائرات ومن قواعد في المنطقه
عاده الطائرات البريطانيه تنطلق من قاعده
اكروتيري في قبرص وتسير لمسافه 3000 ك م
او او اكثر هذه المسافه تساوي بالنسبه
لقائد الطائره مثلا ثان ساعات ذهابا
وايابا بالطائره مع تنفيذ المهمه وبالتالي
الطائرات البريطانيه عاده تحتاج للتزود
بالوقود في الجو في مثل هذه المهمات ا